has your premium for life insurance
uh gone down with your weight
[Laughter]
I just I mean I just got a new policy
and um I have a call about it's like
it's a new type of insurance that I've
never even I think has my tour is so big
they're like oh we can get you into this
big ball or life insurance program now
so I think it's um I don't know what
it's going to be but I think I'm in a
better place for sure for not being huge
and fat yeah yeah and and uh I mean dude
it like you look at your your catalog of
specials yeah and like hey you were a
bigger boy we're you're getting more
handsome as you get older it's just dude
I mean I wish I could
I get mad at myself about it because
like I like I hate I almost you ever
like resent that something's part of
your story
like I like I was I resent yeah my
attempt at becoming a rapper yeah yeah
like you hate that it's a footnote
like I almost like I almost resent you
know my own struggles with weight just
because just because I know it's not um
it wasn't a disease it's not like I'm
not genetically like oh if I eat it's
just from being an overeating
uh sedentary person you know I mean like
yeah but dude is that because like
because I get like that as well touring
on the road like you're in a hotel room
like you kind of want to comfort eat
yeah you know what it really is it was
not it was not dealing with emotions
um in a healthy way I just like an
emotional eater and I would just stuff
myself and like
eat like an [ __ ] and not exercise and
then you go like hey how'd you change
that well I started eating healthier and
exercise like it's it's so simple that I
that it almost just a shame that you're
not in a shame spiral of like
masturbating in a hotel room oh yeah
yeah you just go to bed take a nap
before the show for three hours that's
exactly what and I also feel like that
is um part of that is actually the um
when you don't know what's gonna happen
with your life when you when you're
fully signed up for stand up like fully
signed up for stand up at like 20
so you realize you're like 26 27 so
you know everyone started their careers
kind of out of college that that you
know that I yeah and they're like you're
like all right now I'm like four or five
years removed from that I've been and
now I'm in
and I'm
I'm making a hundred dollars a show
I'm doing six shows
and I have to pay for my plane ticket
and you know like I'm gonna go home with
like two hundred dollars
and I think the the anxiety of of almost
like this is crazy would be a
masturbation
food binging lay around all day kind of
cycle yeah that would yeah it would be
like
recall a bit in one of your earlier
specials about
masturbating in hotel rooms oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean all that [ __ ] was like this
is what I'm I'm talking about you know I
always say like talk about what you know
I'm like this is what I'm this is what
I'm doing like right and then like yeah
I would I and I remember like
I was I remember lying about my weight
in that special in that special I say I
say I'm 245 I remember I do I say I'm
245 I'm 255 in that special and I say
I'm 245 because I'm I think I'm more
comfortable lying about those 10 pounds
and then on the next special
where I'm actually doing like my careers
going better
I'm and I remember I had a gym
membership and I hired at this like the
trainer I'm working out more and I'm I'm
actually like a little bulkier but I'm
eating more I'm actually like 263 in the
next one
and I'm like just and I and then I
remember the end of that like that
special net tour comes out and I got on
a scale and I was I saw I was 268 and I
was like holy [ __ ] this is like really
getting towards the the the big three
zero zero that you don't want to hit and
that's when I was like
but even then it was like you know it's
always been like up down well I it seems
that it's the opposite because you know
you lost the weight and have kept it off
like you didn't well to I think when
you're the person you you're so fixated
on right little amounts because I
actually got a lot I lost a bunch of
weight for the the special that came out
called disgraceful which came out in
2018. then I came 20 pounds which
doesn't sound crazy but the next special
that came out I'm 20 pounds heavier
and I was so ashamed of that so ashamed
of that because like I was so happy
about where I had been before and and
then that special came out then I got
injured
um later that year with the basketball
thing
and that was the thing that really when
I got out of the hospital I was like
I was like man I gotta I gotta finally
try to be consistently healthy like
meaning like yeah not just go pick a
number like because that's the I think
that's the big [ __ ] up for people that
are like trying to manage weight is you
go this is just stick to the number it's
like you gotta just be consistent in
your maintenance it's not about being
like I need to be
to 10 or two like whatever the number is
it's like saying no I gotta Just Eat
Right and exercise and like not be a
piece of [ __ ] yeah all the time and that
that's the difference from now is that I
just try to be consistent with like yeah
what do you do yeah what's your exercise
of choice
um right now I kind of so I mix it up I
have I have a Peloton bike so I do like
I like that for like like on cardio days
I have kettlebells
um I like doing kettlebell circuits you
know so like you do like swings goblets
press like you kind of mix up split
squats and then on the road I bring a
trainer so that's really the game
changers
I bring Sean Nix who's like this super
fit like dude who he's like he's he's
with me like he's like this every day on
the road so it's like he orders lunch
I ordered lunch with him he's like when
are we going to the gym we work out
every day and you're traveling on a tour
bus yeah we fly and then usually the bus
meets us where we fly and then you know
we're in hotels but like you know we
also it's like some hotels have like
these unbelievable gyms some have dog
[ __ ] gyms yeah sometimes there's no gym
and they go there's a [ __ ] you know
like a orange theory down the street
yeah so we just do what we do you know
we bring
we bring our uh boxing equipment that we
might box one day but we never we
basically we have no we don't we really
have no days off you know so we just
consistently do things what's your uh uh
writer like for food
food it's um my green room has turkey
slices and no carbs yeah veggie platter
yeah I mean most days I have yogurt and
blueberries every morning for breakfast
then I have like egg whites and turkey
and then
um we have protein shakes usually every
day 50 grams protein in a shake
and then you know we do a lot of chicken
leaner Cuts I used to always eat like
home to a steakhouse I'd be like what's
the biggest [ __ ] rib eye you have and
I would like
stuff my like it would hurt and I'd be
like you have to fit like crazy [ __ ]
yeah I feel crazy and now it's like oh
no I'll have the eight ounce thing and
I'll be like fully charred rare with
veggies I mean I feel fine with that
yeah it's it's just like do you have a
sauna no I'm one of the only guys in my
circle of friends and everybody's a huge
are you a sauna guy too no we were
talking about it and uh because I'm
dying to know everybody has sauna
everybody and I've been dying to get a
sauna and I'm about to get Asana the
problem is nobody talks about what sauna
they get because there's certain saunas
that like all the research is done at
175 degrees and higher
but I don't know what San is the best
and I was hoping that you had one so you
could tell me which one I'm okay so I am
building my own gym yeah because I want
to have some [ __ ] that I don't I can't
do at my house so I bought a building
and I'm building my own gym and I am
getting a sauna in there and I'm going
to consult with a couple friends about
which one to get yes what about because
I just bought the Morosco Forge ice bath
I got a cold Plunge at the house yeah I
like that
do you like it no but do you love it
afterwards yes
yeah it is a good and you know what
really helped me get through it so I
remember like when I first got it I was
like
all right you know what's the um like I
just looked up like what you know what
like what's the minimum you're supposed
to try to get to it everybody's like you
want to do three minutes
you know start if you can't do that try
to do two try to do a minute you know
whatever
so I get in
I started at like 50 degrees which is
like people don't even respect it like
cold plunge right and I did my three
minutes and then
I was like all right I kept doing three
minutes and I started to lower the
temperature
I was just trying to figure out like how
can I I don't know
do better at this or whatever
you know Wim Hof yeah sure he has this
YouTube video that's um just a breathing
exercise video it has like 40 million
views okay like 40 million and it's him
literally it's not even his face it's
his voice taking you through a breathing
exercise in out now and he's like and
he's got it's a guided breathing
exercise
and you see numbers as the breath is is
animated right
I did it with him with do it so I put
that on top of the like the you know the
cold plunge cover as I was sitting there
and then I kind of just and then he's
like now take this break and now let's
do the next sequence
and that's designed for breathing while
you're in a cold Pun It's actually you
can use it for that or just um guided
breathing even like if you want to just
like start your day
you know like because it has multiple
benefits but it's particularly helpful
in that setting and in the cold plunge
setting I think
first time I do it with him in like 47
degree water six minutes because I
wasn't even I was lost
in the breath guidance so like highly
recommend if you're going to try that or
if you're trying to improve to pull up
that video and just let you won't even
be aware of time it's just you just have
Wim Hof taking you through it yeah you
got a cold plan it's been sitting in my
front yard for literally months I don't
even know how many months a lot of
months I haven't even tried it yet try
it I haven't even tried it yet and the
last I heard was that like inside it's
just like
growing mold yeah we gotta we gotta
figure she doesn't have that treated
yeah but do you notice the difference in
your sleeping and all that with after
the cold do you notice any difference
from it oh my god well the the first
thing is like
when you get out and in the moments
afterward I uh after there's all types
of actual chemical
um releases going on yeah your brain is
releasing a number of real
um endorphins and like yeah what is it
Noreen epinephrine yes all that is
actually so you do have this sense of
like Euphoria and and like I mean you
you feel like you invigorated yes you're
very invigorated yeah well it's a dope
feeling it really is all right I don't
have to try it because that's a whoop
strap right yeah and
are you noticing good recoveries after
you do ice bath like which when you wake
up in the morning what's your percentage
of recovery normally it's been rough for
me lately it has been my travel and and
I'm on 99 recovery
and I'm like 34 or something but I think
I think that's nine today I got last
night I went into bed like
aberrationally early
so I did like I'm normally like a night
guy and I just tapped out but dude like
we will have a called whoop and Steve's
like yeah my HRV recovery is like 140
and they're like what like triathletes
don't even have that that is incredible
what do you what do you attribute that
to
um it's it's how good of a job I'm doing
at avoiding sugar really yeah I noticed
that like when I cut out sugar my HIV
goes way up
my um that is my you know everybody had
like when I was used to I used to want
to just like lose weight people would go
like cut out your drinking and I'm like
yeah I don't really drink and then they
just go oh
thanks for the advice how about Bert
yeah
my whoop recovery is off the charts he's
so proud of his tequila Discovery I mean
he really feel he really feels like he
made like like like a Doctor Who's like
you know what is causing cancer like he
feels like he made an actual Landmark
Discovery with tequila yeah all the
comments on our on the video that I
posted about that clip he was like yeah
that's an alcoholic talking right there
oh yeah
and he's like telling he's like here's
what you need to do you don't need to
stop drinking you need to start drinking
tequila like he's really yeah proud of
this and I'm like you think that's what
it is he's like a hundred percent
so out of his mind
um now for me I have noticed so much of
how my life is like how everything in
this shell is affected by Sugar yeah if
I dude like it's not just weight
digestion like inflammation and
everything mood and if I and I can have
this like
thing where I won't have I could I'll
have incidental incidental sugars are
what I call like you know this thing has
two grams of sugar in it right you're
like whatever but I mean if you go like
I want sugar like I want a brownie or
whatever you know I mean like a donut
can have that and be like fine but if
you go like
let's have another one and let's have
one tomorrow like and I build a pattern
it hey it only within a couple days I
notice a complete transformation like a
complete downward spiral and
like we're both like
addicts in every sense of the word so
like if I open that cage door a little
crack the whole gorilla comes out sugar
is my favorite one it's my favorite one
it's not it's the number one drug in the
world it is yeah and I can like people
go like if you had to like you know like
because high fat is very satiating right
like something like rich and for sure
and butter and unlike of course
delicious but if you go me like give me
the option I'll be like oh sugar sugar
every time yeah like on the way here I
had a headache I woke up in the morning
had coffee whatever had a headache and
then I was like man I need to eat
something and they had mango dehydrated
mango in the front on the way here and I
and I ate a couple my headache went away
and I'm like 22 grams of sugar for a
[ __ ] dehydrated mango I'm like I just
drank a Coke yeah my headache's gone
I think it's Sugar's incredible it's
incredible they think that like
when I went taking tours of the the
Mayan ruins they were like dude these
[ __ ] ruins were around for 10 000
years or 5 000 years and then when the
British came when they invented when
they started like teaching them how to
mill for sugar everybody's scattered
because they the diseases started
happening and diabetes and people
started dying off that they thought the
land was cursed so they left but really
what happened was
they started teaching them how to like
make rum from all the sugar cane and
[ __ ] and like they left within 100 Years
of that happening because everybody
started dying of diseases unbelievable I
mean it's called Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and if you go on Amazon
and type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're at ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude